I think that I know he's saying that
many invented the pill
but somebody must have invented cyan
eyes or poison nobody make them take it
right so just because somebody's making
something
it that means that oh you can go ahead
and take it and when it comes to single
parents
you can understand you saying
I've only got one child single parent
one child
but when you get women having free four
five six seven children eight I think
there's some out there nine that was
still looking for dates sometimes by
nine different fathers can't put it all
on demand I'll say yeah the first one
yeah because
a lot of men
don't ask to be fathers
they don't ask to be fathers my son's
dad never asked to be a father actually
just I was on the pill it was an
accident I actually discussed it with
him
and even though he agreed that I have
the child
I was
I knew that if I had to raise him on my
own I did because he never asked for him
and I don't believe in abortion
so as far as I'm concerned
single parent says no excuse even if the
father's not there there's plenty of
really good Role Models out there male
role models you know you've got the
grandfathers you've got the uncles
you've got the really good friends
and then you should be able to do that
with a child without expecting anything
my son is 36 years old I think in all
his life I took 100 pounds from his dad
that's what I asked for 100 pound for
his dad
and when they say that oh the government
supports him and everything and I
remember at the time I was studying and
they said oh you know you get extra
money for being a single parent but they
want to know who the dad is and I said
nope take your money
take your money it's not a good
influence so my son take your money I'll
do it on my own but he always had good
Role Models yes and that's important and
that's important too many they make too
many single parents make it look so hard
you know it's hard when you don't keep
on it's hard when you don't know how to
shut your legs when you don't know how
to shut your legs and you don't know how
to get both control of course it's going
to be hard now bearing in mind there's
no excuses I'm the exception to every
rule there is out there I'm the
exception
any situation I can say I'm the
exception to everything so I'm a rarity
but I know a lot of single parents and
either for that was some of them that
are friends of mine because I was a
hard-working person I can afford for
them to have children and they're not
working but I couldn't afford for me to
have any more yes because I was hard
working so I can't even say put it on
the men because at the end of the day
yeah you can say put a condom you think
that after getting pregnant on the pill
that I just relied on the pill I just
relied on the condom I was using
everything there was you name it even if
I had the injection and they said it's
90 I'm still using a condom even if I
was on the pill I'm still using a condom
so it's got to be down to the women yeah
because at the end of the day
a single parent with more than one child
for the same person I can understand
that but a single parent with loads of
little
I was gonna say little nigglets
that's just a saying that's in my head
yeah
but the little babies yeah and you've
got loads of them running around I
remember I grew up with a girl and and
she was like the black version of
Angelina Jolie I saw her and every
single nationality you see she slept
with maybe to try them out
you know and they were oh she never had
two kids that resembled each other and
they were all hers so she didn't
discriminated at the end of the day and
you're saying that
I'm playing deva's advocate here because
I've got one child for my son's dad yes
guess how many children he's got my
son's a second now the third guess how
many how many he he's got the father of
your child
oh boy I mean I don't know sixteen
sixteen okay wow 16. I was gonna say
eight
[Music]
so you're trying to tell me that all
right then the first one I think he was
at school and it was a school like there
was both at school the second one was
supposed to be my son but I knew I knew
different I knew there was another one
out there that's why I said third
because he's still trying to convince us
it's a second okay
all of his children know their parents
all of his children know their dad
you're just trying to tell me that
you've got
you see a man and he's got two children
a different parent three children
how the hell are you gonna get to the
woman who said number 16. then he got
married to somebody that have no
children for him
but you see I mean so you can't keep on
sometimes the women shut your legs it's
both I mean it takes shut your legs
because the women that go out there and
they will see a man and they think oh
he's this and this but the difference is
it's 80 90 well it's like it's most
women where it's a small percentage of
men and so you're gonna say what
percentage of men that want sorry that
it's a small percentage of men that
women want and so that are doing that's
what I'm saying like it's such a small
percentage So when you say it's it's the
men too it's like yeah okay it's 5 10
whatever it is and then when you get the
children they can't see that I'm not
sure I get what's being argued against
here no who's to blame for like you know
single parents you know it's all
sometimes they say it's all about the
women so is it about the man to me to me
and I think sometimes the single parents
they they yeah the women use it they use
the sympathy yeah to me it's to me it's
completely 50 50. like it's literally to
me it's to me it's literally 50. I don't
think it's 50 50. as a single parent I
don't think it's 50 50. I don't I mean
if I go out there and I father 16 kids
I don't know why I would be absolved
yeah of the fact that I've chosen to go
out there we have more control like we
can be out we you can get an IUD it's 99
effective you don't have that control
we do we do too it's pretty strong
extent it's not but the women don't want
to get pregnant like if you want like
I'm not saying like like some you know
what I mean if if I wanted to have 16
kids I could have 16 kids
why are women choosing to have 16 Shoes
all right then some of them have got
five children I could even just be just
like if I were a snake I could even be
completely deceptive about it like oh
I've got 14. no he wasn't I'm saying you
could as a man yeah as a cat you could I
could have you could have 12 kids out
there and go and have a 13th with
another she's not even aware about the
of the other 12 or whatever you can say
whatever you know even promise oh you
know we're gonna get we're going to do
this
again
dude there's some dudes in this
situation they were all aware no even
girls girl they know and this is what
irritates me is they'll they'll act like
they don't know they might not know that
like maybe 13 kids they might not know
but you know when a dude is sleeping
around you do and I don't believe it for
a second when these girls say oh I
didn't know I found out the difference
between sleeping around and fathering or
just having a ton of kids I mean to me
it's to me it's a 50 50 thing some of
them I mean
from another woman ninety percent I'm
with you there what do you think um
because and what makes it worse is that
they choose the bad men and then they're
proud of her at the time and then when
it doesn't work they blame the men you
know either woman come up to me
Woolworths isn't there anymore but she
came up to me with a baby and said he's
got a boy now say he's and I thought you
already had two girls
you're not with him
and you're gonna approach me to say that
he's got a son because I I'm the only
one with one and I thought to myself why
would you do that why would you even go
there and have more children
you know but all that all the women knew
all the women knew that he had all these
children they always they always know
they always know and then they blame him
oh but he knows as well like I don't
understand why we are absorbing all
responsibility from the man he's had
three children
would you have a chance
he can control that as well yeah make
sure she's on the pill is she lies I was
on the pill yeah but that's different
because you were on the pill but it's
like you literally you you know that
some you're having sex could potentially
have a child yes you know that yes you
didn't do anything to make sure she
stops this happening how can you then
have no responsibility I'm not I'm not
disagree like yes men men have a part to
play but I just think it's more on the
women because we have control we are in
control of birth if you if you get
pregnant you can get an abortion men
have no say in that so until that's
equal I can't say we're in equally at
fault
um
I think in terms and if we have 41 forms
of birth control what men have won and
we're also in control of the people that
we sleep with you can require they wear
a condom as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible